what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course the spider-verse spider-man no
way home is one of the biggest movies of
all time and luckily for us spoiler
alert if you haven't seen spider-man
knowing home and it's post-credits scene
luckily for us the spider-man knowing
home post-credit scene set up another
spider-man film and not to mention
marvel studios president kevin feige and
sony executive producer amy pascale not
too long after the theatrical release of
no way home came out and said that they
are indeed working on another spider-man
film with tom holland kevin feige said
he was letting us know so we didn't have
to worry about another sony marvel
studios mix-up so it's confirmed we're
getting another spider-man movie in the
mcu and it looks like we are getting a
trilogy actually and this trilogy has
the potential to be way better than the
trilogy that we already have with tom
holland in fact spider-man 4 spider-man
4 in the mcu with tom holland not a
spider-man 4 with tobey maguire which i
will talk about but spider-man 4 with
tom holland alone could actually be
better than spider-man no way home if
even some of these rumors are true so
let's dive into what we already know
about these upcoming movies and how they
could actually lead up to an amazing
trilogy one that hopefully outdoes the
first one and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos now one of
the cool things is is that we actually
know what spider-man 4 is going to be
about or at least we know a little bit
about what the plot is going to entail
again thanks to its post-credits scene
teasing the venom symbiote but what if
spider-man 4 is more than just a venom
vs spider-man film after all we have tom
hardy's venom but he is back in the sony
universe marvel teased this with the
post-credits scene for venom let there
be carnage tom hardy's venom and eddie
brock going to the mcu but then in the
post credits for noah home they went
back and they left behind a part of the
venom symbiote which makes it very clear
that it's not going to be the same eddie
brock and venom from the sony
spider-verse seemingly setting up a
spider-man vs venom with a new venom but
what if it's not just venom what if it's
a whole bunch of symbiotes and what if
the other two spider-men return and help
tom holland's peter parker fight them
now at this point in time it seems all
but confirmed that tobey maguire and
andrew garfield in some way shape or
form are going to return again and
reprise their roles as their respective
spider-man this could be cameos in other
movies such as andrew garfield
spider-man appearing in morbius the big
rumor right now is that there's a
spider-man in one of the post-credits
scenes and it could be andrews not to
mention toby maguire said that he was
really really excited to get back in the
suit and that he is up for anything and
recently sam raimi who directed the
original spider-man trilogy with tobey
maguire and is now directing multiverse
of madness said that he would love to
direct another spider-man film then not
to mention one deleted scene from
spider-man no way home a very very
important scene where tom holland's
peter parker is leaving the other two
spider-man he's saying goodbye to them
and there's one version of this scene
where andrew garfield's peter parker
says you know where to find us implying
that if peter parker did need some help
again he would know exactly where to go
to find the other two spider-men now the
scene was deleted and didn't make the
final cut for whatever reason perhaps
they didn't want people like me looking
too much into this but the point is
there is so much happening that does
lead us to believe that toby and andrew
will eventually return in some way shape
or form and perhaps they could return in
spider-man 4. a big rumor right now is
that they are going to return for
another spider-man movie with tom
holland but they're going to be in the
movie for the majority of the time and
not just one part now right off the bat
that alone would probably beat no way
home let me clarify i don't think the
hype would be as big as spider-man no
way home but i think once that movie did
come out and it was truly a three
spider-man film it would eventually be
no way home and then if you add some
other rumors that are going around about
the three spider-man fighting a symbiote
army that would essentially give you
spider-man vs venom but times three
probably more than that but it would be
really cool if you saw one spider-man go
up against one venom another against
another and then another against another
3v3 that would be pretty sweet now null
the symbiote creator in god was rumored
to possibly appear in thor love and
thunder but it appears that some
insiders have shut that rumor down and
that could be because sony wants to use
null themselves perhaps in the next
spider-man film they do need to go
bigger with the next spider-man film and
how do you go bigger than the three
spider-man showing up well there kind of
are two options one you can do with
spider-man vs venom which it seems like
they are indeed doing and two you could
have the three spider-man in an entire
movie and not just one part this could
make spider-man 4 better than spider-man
no way home and fingers crossed that
something like this actually does happen
but i do think that something else in
spider-man 4 has to happen to make the
future of the trilogy amazing because i
do think that even if this is heavily
focused on the symbiotes they do have to
set spider-man 5 and 6 up for something
extremely big to come and i think one
thing they have to introduce in
spider-man 4 is kingpin now of course as
most of us know kingpin has already been
introduced into the mcu in the hawkeye
series and no he is not dead he gets
shot in the eyes in the comics goes
blind but eventually recovers his
eyesight this is going to happen in the
mcu and we believe that he's going to be
the big bad villain of the echo series
and not to mention it looks like
daredevil is going to be getting his own
mcu disney plus series as well and what
better villain to bring in than kingpin
plus not to mention we know that peter
parker and matt murdock now know each
other thanks to spider-man no way home
so this would also set up a team up for
daredevil and spider-man something i
know myself and a lot of fans have
really really been wanting so i think a
kingpin setup at least has to happen in
spider-man 4. this will lead to
spider-man 5. now spider-man 5 can be
about kingpin he can be the main
spider-man villain this could also be
where daredevil actually comes into play
in a spider-man film because i do
actually think that spider-man 6 should
be just about r peter parker our
spider-man it'll be the finale of the
trilogy and maybe even the finale of tom
holland playing spider-man it should
probably just focus on him so if we are
gonna see a daredevil spider-man team up
i do believe it should be in spider-man
5 against kingpin however i do not
believe that they should kill kingpin in
spider-man 5 i think it should reappear
in spider-man 6 with the sinister 6 with
norman osborne backing them up now we
still have no idea who bought the
avengers tower in the mcu right now it
could go on to be the baxter building
for the fantastic four we'll have to
wait and see on that but we do know that
there is no norman osborn in the mcu
that has been revealed at least i think
this is what spider-man 6 should be
focused on especially since we've
already met a norman osborne slash the
green goblin in the mcu at this point
and as we know he killed aunt may and
peter parker even though he saved him
probably still has a lot of aggressive
feelings towards him now what's actually
really interesting is very recently
marissa tome who plays aunt may said
that she would love to return in the mcu
stating that it's the multiverse and
pretty much anything is possible now
imagine if a variant of hers somehow
returned that would make things super
interesting if tom holland's peter
parker went up against a green goblin
now of course we all kind of wanted a
sinister six a true sinister six for a
big finale we got the sinister five but
as the writers and producers of
spider-man know home stated they weren't
really meant to be the sinister six they
were just villains so spider-man
6 should be a sinister six movie with
norman osborne at the helm you can have
norman osborne kingpin craven the hunter
because we do have a crave in the hunter
film coming up and let's not forget
vulture scorpion and chameleon do exist
in the mcu their characters were kind of
introduced and then sidelined by the
huge movie that was no way home but they
do still exist and we're going to be
seeing michael keaton's vulture in
morbius at least we think so we'll have
to see what they're doing with the
universes here maybe he's a variant who
knows but i am hoping at least michael
keaton's vulture would still be in the
mcu and would be a part of the sinister
six heck maybe even a venom symbiote
could be left over and venom could be a
part of the sinister six and i
personally think that if all of this
happens this trilogy could actually be
way better than the homecoming trilogy
the three spider-man returning for a
full movie spider-man vs venom in some
way shape or form kingpin one of the
biggest baddest spider-man villains
being introduced in the mcu as a main
spider-man villain and a true sinister
six with norman osborne i think this
would outdo the homecoming trilogy but
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel videos for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof